- Is it, is it true that you got
in trouble for showering
at a gas station once?
'Cause I need the story.
- It nearly got me arrested. That's true.
I was traveling around America
as a young, young traveler.
I was about 20-21 at the
time and I just slept
in my car because I couldn't
find a room that night.
And I went to freshen up
in the morning, Kelly,
as you do. And I couldn't
find a shower anywhere,
but I found a gas station that was closed
and I realized that, you
know, well, the tap is there
and I'll just kind of try
and freshen up onto the tap.
So I was sitting on the
ground, on the concrete trying
to freshen up. I want
to say I was clothed,
I just wanna say it, I was clothed, okay?
And I wanted to get my head underneath.
And as a lot of tall people struggle
with when you're staying in a cheap hotel,
when the force that doesn't
quite make, you know,
you've got to do that thing
where you kind of bend
down and get underneath.
- [Kelly] I wouldn't know.
- And I was trying to do that to-
- I'm 5'3, so.
- It has its advantages
when you're on the road,
Kelly, as you know.
- Yeah. So it is nice.
- So I was literally, you know, in a kind
of contortionist position under this tap
and someone in an apartment
building next door yelled out,
you know, "You can't do that,
sir. You can not take a shower
under a tap," and called the police.
And the police came and
my excuse was, I said,
"I'm sorry, but I'm Australian.
And I don't have anywhere to..."
Anyway, I didn't get arrested, Kelly.
And I can't remember if
I found a shower that day
or not actually, but there you go.
- Hey, I have several experiences.
It wasn't in public, but
my place burned down here
in LA when I was a
teenager moved down here,
and I had nowhere to go,
but I had a gym membership.
So I think they started
noticing I was taking showers
and like getting ready
for my job. I was like-
- She's skipping the workout.
She's coming in for the shower,
but I didn't see the bit where-
- I wasn't working out-
- We saw this.
- I was just showing up, you
know , around opening time
to get ready for, yeah. Hey,
you have to do what works.